you know who else is happy uh living in
one of your relationships everybody
talking about you and aubrey plaza oh
boy
i mean this is like
click bait headlines around the world
you premiered your movies spin me round
at south by southwest you and aubry have
a kissing scene make out scenes
something and it is literally all the
rage people are flipping out about it i
i have to say
that i i took a little break from doing
press for a minute i was working and
covid was happening
i hadn't been doing you know you get in
a groove where you're doing interviews
and you're like really good at it
and i forgot about click bait as a thing
and just was like
yeah make out scene it was great it was
my favorite night on set like you say
these things
totally delicious hyperbolic isms that
become clickbait headlines yes and also
because we shot so much other stuff that
night so i was t that that doesn't get
included in the article where i was like
it was my favorite night of shooting we
shot a scene in a dance club we shot a
scene where aubry steals a vespa they're
like okay it was the best night of my
life how's the makeout
well then they're just like they made
out it was the best night of my life and
i'm like
so i gotta text aubrey and be like sorry
or do you need to text dave
and you're just fine with it and like
then i'm like all right like okay if
you're kissing dave franco on set or
you're kissing aubrey plaza
you know
who who are you having more fun with
who's more comfortable
what are you talking to aubry about what
are you talking to dave about in
fairness um you know this spin me around
is a movie that i wrote with my writing
partner jeff bana this is our second
film that we've written and produced
together but it's my fourth film that
i've done with jeff and jeff is aubrey's
husband i love that you guys uh make
films that you collaborate that you have
these deep rooted friendships that you
also create and collaborate with you're
just putting
goodness out into the world both of you
amazing couples just keep doing it
because it's so good it's so good
it's so fun for all of us
um
okay your current project roar now it's
like nicole kidman and you and people
are really talking about this
it's highly anticipated
people are freaking out critical acclaim
already
or
um i watched your episode last night
great and um tell us about why
everybody's talking about this show yes
well it's such a cool concept it was
created by the two women that also
created glow liz flay hive and carly
mensch
and it's based off a book of short
stories which are these feminist fables
so it's an anthology series it's eight
different episodes and each episode
is stars a different woman is directed
by a woman written by a woman they are
these feminist powerhouse stories but
they're told with some magical
surrealism some dark
comedy they all have a sense of humor to
them yeah i like how deep they can go
without being heavy and dark
i i love it and i think it is worth all
the hype and i can't wait for people to
see it
[Music]
you